let's actually a question from Reddit uh
what the long-term effects of human
communication when people can talk with
in quotes talk with others through a
chatbot that augments their language
automatically rather than developing
social skills by making mistakes and
learning uh will people just communicate
by grunts in a generation hey do you
think about long-term effects at scale
the integration of AI in our social
interaction
yeah I mean I think it's mostly
good I I mean that that was that
question was sort of framed in a
negative way but I mean we were talking
before about
language models helping you communicate
with it was like language translation
helping you communicate with people who
don't speak your language I mean at some
level
with all this social technology is doing
is helping people
um
Express themselves
better to people
in in situations where they would
otherwise have a hard time doing that so
part of it might be okay because you
speak a language that I don't know
that's a pretty basic one that you know
I don't think people are going to look
at that and say it's sad that do we have
the capacity to do that because I should
have just learned your language right I
mean that's that's pretty high bar but
um
but overall I'd say um
there are all these impediments
in language is an imperfect way
for people to express thoughts and ideas
it's you know one of the best that we
have we have that we have art we have
code but language is also a mapping of
the way you think the way you see the
world the way who you are and one of the
applications I've recently talked to a
person who who's uh actually a jiu-jitsu
instructor
um he said that when he uh emails
parents about
their son and daughter
um that they can improve their
discipline in class and so on he often
finds that he comes off a bit of more of
an [__] than he would like so he uses
GPT to translate his original email into
a nicer email
we hear this all the time a lot of
creators on our services tell us that
one of the most stressful things
um is basically negotiating deals with
Brands and stuff like the business side
of it because they're like I mean they
do their thing right and and you know
the creators they're they're excellent
at what they do and they just want to
connect with their Community but then
they get really stressed you know they
go into their their DMS and they see
some brand wants to do some with them
and they
don't quite know how to negotiate or how
to push back respectfully and so I think
building a tool that can actually allow
them to do that well is you know one
simple thing that that I think is just
like an interesting thing that that
we've heard from a bunch of people that
that they'd be interested in but I'm
going back to the broader idea
um
I I don't know I mean you know I just
Priscilla and I just had our third
daughter
um congratulations thank you
and and you know it's like one of the
saddest things in the world is like
seeing your baby cry right but like it's
like what why is that right it's like
well because babies don't generally have
much capacity to tell you what they
care about otherwise right it's not
actually just babies right it's um you
know my five-year-old daughter cries too
because she sometimes has a hard time
expressing you know what what um matters
to to her and and I was thinking about
that and it's like well you know
actually a lot of adults get very
frustrated too because they can't they
have a hard time expressing things in a
way that going back to some of the early
themes that
maybe is something that you know is a
mistake or maybe they have pride or
something like all these things get in
the way so I don't know I think that all
these different technologies that can
help us navigate the social complexity
and actually be able to better express
our what we're feeling and thinking I
think that's generally all good and um
there are always these concerns like
okay are people gonna have worse
memories because you have Google to look
things up and and I think in general a
generation later you don't look back and
lament that I think it's just like wow
we have so much more capacity to to do
so much more now and I think that
that'll be the case here too you can
allocate those cognitive capabilities to
like deeper like nuanced thought yeah